[Applause]
[Music]
what do you do when your web service
loses access to the internet well if the
service is running on Google Cloud you
file a support case like this one from a
real Google Cloud customer they've
rebooted the virtual machine they've
tested the network but something's very
wrong the case gets filed with a
priority of P1 production down
that means Google Cloud's support
response will follow the sun no matter
what time of day or night the ticket
will route to a regional support team
that's online in this case it's time for
a little trip to Zurich Switzerland we
usually have people who like to solve
problems
and uh in some cases we we are lucky
enough to get very interesting problem
this is Antonio at the time of this
story he was a Technical Solutions
engineer at Google Cloud support team in
Zurich his job solved the case of the
missing Network packets by the time
Antonio receives the case the customer
has found a workaround so the issue is
no longer critical but the concern the
mysterious network problems could still
pop up on other machines so we set up a
meeting with the current agent and one
of the engineers from the from the
company we started trying to
understanding a bit better the issue
depending on some issues that they are
usually common to many customers when
you go and we check like these two three
things that are always well 90 90 of the
case they are the
um
in this case however the reason why the
case was not solved yet was because all
The Usual Suspects were no at fault
because Google Cloud works hard to
ensure customer privacy Antonio doesn't
have access to the virtual machine
himself so every idea about fixing the
problem has to be passed along to the
customer to test on their side One By
One The Usual Suspects are eliminated by
the end of Antonio's shift there's still
no explanation for why the network
packets aren't making it onto the
customer's machine the case follows the
sun around to the next support team
while Antonio gets some rest
by this time the case is famous inside
Google Cloud support another support
engineer uses python to create a raw DNS
packet and sends a request to the
virtual machine's metadata server but
when the customer runs the code the DNS
reply comes back successfully as strange
as it sounds this confirms that the
networking problem is actually not a
network problem it's something wrong
with the software on the VM itself
Google Cloud support could say you know
this is your configuration this is not
some thinking we support so please fix
your configuration but at this point I
was kinda invested it was a bit like
reading a tree there and then getting to
the point where you know that the
investigator found out who is the who's
the Killer and you don't realize it yet
by now Antonio is back on shift and has
decided to take personal ownership of
the problem from now on the good news is
that the customer has offered to give
him an image of the virtual machine so
he can run tests safely without so much
back and forth so we had a lot of
conflicting information this is when we
took a step back and we tried to analyze
in a more scientific way let's say there
are only so many places where these DNS
packets could disappear so like any good
detective Antonio begins to form
hypotheses and rule them out one by one
the operating system libraries use the
call DNS are working fine DNS packets
and configuration files on the machine
look correct reinstalling the kernel
doesn't fix anything
there's nothing wrong with the firewall
configuration and DNS requests and
replies are correctly being sent and DNS
resolution fails even when bypassing the
metadata service that leaves one
possibility a bug in the Linux kernel
itself so I spent some more time maybe
one day troubleshooting the issue inside
the Linux scan and I managed to find
where exactly in the Linux kernel the
packet was dropped and why and at that
point I just created a pull request and
fix the bug on the Kernel
main release an integer overflow deep
within the Linux kernel turns out to be
the source of the trouble the bug is
patched the case is closed the customer
can move on and Google Cloud's support
detectives await their next mystery to
solve
join us next time for another case from
Google Cloud support files
[Music]